des rendez vous d'affaires individuels
qui côtoient des technologies très
futuriste lors de cette manifestation
annuelle consacrée à l'innovation en
plus de nouer de nombreux contacts avec
des partenaires les entreprises
yvelinoise ont notamment pu découvrir
les opportunités qu'offre l'impression
3d l'impression 3d permet la production
de masse de pièces sur mesure et on n'a
pas tous le même fémur on n'a pas tous
le même crâne et donc l'impression 3d à
une débouché naturel sur l'environnement
médical mais pas que parce que toutes
les industries aujourd'hui nous
sollicitent à travers l'europe est
également aux états unis en asie
autre technologie qui a envahi notre
quotidien depuis ces dernières années la
réalité augmentée un procédé développé
notamment à elancourt dans les locaux
d'airbus defence and space on va venir
ajouter des informations digitales à
votre réalité dire qu'on va venir
pointer des objets et leur indiquer leur
nature
on a présenté un petit peu ce qu'on a
fait autour d'une application qui est
une des premiers cas d'utilisation dans
le monde de l'éducation comment utiliser
la réalité augmentée pour améliorer la
capacité dans le cadre du training
l'information guider les entreprises
yvelinoise pour qu'elles s'approprient
ces nouvelles technologies numériques
c'était la volonté de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie dans les
yvelines 14,1 pour cent des emplois sur
les à l'industrie contre 12,3 au niveau
1 au niveau national et seulement 7,6 au
niveau de toute la région ile de france
est donc c'était aussi une bonne raison
de mettre l'accent sur l'industrie et
l'industrie du futur des entreprises qui
ont pu également découvrir un nouveau
dispositif open connect lab destiné à
mieux développer leurs innovations